c'est un outil magnifique et intense est
devenue un enfer à gérer aujourd'hui on
va parler notre relation aux smartphones
parce que je sais pas vous mais moi j'ai
une relation hyper conflictuelles avec
mon téléphone à la fois je kiffe
l'utiliser et en même temps c'est un
vortex qui me bouffe beaucoup trop de
temps pour s'en va voir d'abord une
partie un peu théorique son autre
addiction et ensuite une partie pratique
sur comment limiter sa voulais aussi
vous remercier grandement pour vos
retours sur la dernière vidéo cd retour
qui m'ont vraiment touché si vous n'êtes
pas abonné n'hésitez pas à le faire pour
ne pas rater du contenu qui j'espère
sera le plus qualitatif possible et je
vais essayer de m'accrocher à serait
depuis que j'ai depuis quelques semaines
la d'une vidéo toutes les deux semaines
on va l'essayer ce souci avec le
téléphone je suis pas le seul à l'avoir
en 2014
kevin volet ch a créé une app qui
s'appelle mommens le but c'est de
monitorer son temps d'écran et donc il a
pu avoir accès à un tas de données de
ses utilisateurs et donc il a pu faire
des petites études il leur demandait
combien de temps il pensait passer sur
leur téléphone et ils ont répondu en
moyenne 90 minutes par jour à queue il y
avait les données et donc il avait le
vrai temps est ce vrai temps était
plutôt de trois heures par jour et le
fait de consulter son téléphone une
quarantaine de fois trois heures par
jour ça arrive vite
donc ce que ça nous dit surtout c'est
qu'il ya un décalage claire entre le
lien qu'on pense à voir avec son
téléphone et le lien qu'on a réellement
et ça ça nous permet de parler d'un
concept clé parce que on parle de notre
relation avec le téléphone c'est le
concept d' addiction il y avait pas mal
d'idées reçues sur l'addiction avant que
ce soit étudiée on pensait notamment par
exemple que ça ne touchait que ceux qui
n'avaient pas de volonté puis on a fait
une observation on a observé les soldats
américains qui revenaient de la guerre
du vietnam et consommer une forme
extrêmement pur le l'héroïne c'est bien
qu'à la fin de la guerre il ya 19 % des
soldats qui se déclarait addict donc
c'est énorme
les robbins une psychiatre de
l'université de washington s'est
intéressé à leur cas elle savait que
seulement 3 à 5% des héroïnomanes
pouvait arrêter après un traitement
et pourtant après le traitement des
soldats c'est 95% d'entre eux qui ont
totalement arrêtée pourquoi pourquoi
gifle aussi énorme quand on s'attendait
à beaucoup moins les raisons elles sont
en fait plutôt simple
situation beaucoup moins stressante et
héroïne beaucoup moins accessible
mais surtout c'est le genre d'histoire
qui permet de réaliser que l'addiction
peut toucher vraiment tout le monde
et qu'elle dépend beaucoup de
l'environnement et non seulement de la
personnalité alors maintenant qu'on sait
que l'addiction elle peut toucher tout
le monde ça peut être intéressant de
voir la puissance que ça sur notre
cerveau et pour ça on va avoir une
expérience de james holmes sur les rats
dans les années 50
auld a découvert par hasard le centre du
plaisir dans le cerveau du rat et du
coup il ya fait une expérience en y
plaçant une électrode qui permet aux
rats de stimuler la zone en appuyant sur
un bouton
en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que les
rats ils passaient leur temps à appuyer
sur le bouton sans cesse si bien que il
s'alimentait même pas et du coup il en
mourait on a fait la même expérience
avec des singes ça donnait même résultat
on l'a pas fait avec les humains mais on
peut penser que tous les animaux et donc
y compris les humains peuvent être
addict sous de bonnes conditions
enfin les bonnes conditions les bonnes
conditions par rapport à l'expérience
bon d'être addict je pense que vous avez
vous personnellement j'ai eu beaucoup de
mal à parler d'addition par rapport à ma
relation avec mon téléphone
peut-être parce que c'est pas une
addiction de substances mais c'est une
addictions comportementales
si les addictions qui sont tout aussi
graves les plus courantes c'est par
exemple le sexe les jeux d'argent les
jeux vidéo est aujourd'hui le téléphone
et pourtant selon la neuroscientifique
claire gillian de la campost university
ces comportements peuvent stimuler les
mêmes zones du cerveau qui sont
stimulées par des drogues comme
l'héroïne ou la cocaïne par rapport aux
smartphones la clé c'est dans la
dopamine
alors la dopamine c'est un
neurotransmetteur qui va influer sur
notre comportement parce qu'il va créer
des sensations de plaisir comme une
récompense qui va renforcer un certain
comportement du coup ça aussi une forte
influence sur la motivation par exemple
et notre smartphone et les applis qui
sont dessus ont été conçus pour nous
procurer cette dopamine et donc nous
inciter à les utiliser davantage
notamment avec son appel la compulsion
loupé ce qu'on pourrait traduire par la
boucle de compulsion cette boucle se
fait en trois parties d'abord il ya
l'anticipation de recevoir la récompense
ensuite il y à l'activité qu'il faut
faire pour recevoir la récompense
enfin il y à l'action d'obtenir la
récompense alors la dopamine a créé un
sentiment de plaisir et de motivation et
même si la substance n'est pas
addictives en elle-même elle crée un
comportement addictif parce que on va
rechercher notre prochaine libération de
deux
amine est d'ailleurs fait que j'ai
trouvé intéressant c'est dopamine elle
est créée dans le cerveau au moment de
l'anticipation du fait de recevoir une
récompense
c'est après seulement qu'elle est
libérée mais la création est ce déjà
lors de l'anticipation
l'un des domaines dans lequel cet homme
pulsionnel ou pas les flagrantes c'est
les jeux vidéo notamment les plus
addictifs comme par exemple qu indique
roche credit crunch donc andy crush vous
avez plein de petites victoires
immédiate world récompense immédiate et
donc elles vont libérer de la dopamine
et du coup vous allez avoir envie de les
enchaîner une certaine manière le like
instagram leurs tweets twitter c'est une
petite victoire à la candy croche et
c'est ça aussi qui rend les réseaux
sociaux aussi addictif mais il ya un
autre élément à ajouter
c'est l'un prédictibilité mot compte
triple il n'y a pas de prédictibilité
c'est à dire que vous ne pouvez pas
savoir à l'avancé si vous allez avoir
beaucoup de laïcs retweet etc ou bien au
contraire pas du tout cette
imprévisibilité elle rend la chose
encore plus addictives il y a une
expérience de 1970 sur des pigeons qui
va dans ce sens c'est une expérience de
michael eiler il a pris des pigeons il a
mis dans une cage les miens bouton et
quand ils s'appuient sur ce bouton ils
reçoivent de la nourriture
l'invention que en trois quarts des
expériences sur les animaux
à cette époque c'était ce à quoi tu
aimais dans une cage via un bouton il a
pu utilisons la nourriture ben voilà il
a remarqué que si les pigeons recevaient
une récompense à chaque fois qu'ils
appuient sur le bouton et bien il
appuyait régulièrement mais peu
fréquemment alors que si il avait une
récompense seulement 50 à 70% des fois
où il appuie sur le bouton like
d'appuyer fréquemment et obstinément
d'où le fait que ce soit encore plus
fort avec les réseaux sociaux puisque on
peut perdre beaucoup
c'est à dire avoir la sensation de pas
avoir d'amis dre abandonné etc ou bien
on peut gagner beaucoup c'est à dire
avoir la sensation d'être aimée etc on
pourrait aussi parler du fait que le
smartphone est toujours avec nous voilà
toujours dans une poche dans un sac etc
enfin vraiment il est à la portée de nos
mains ce qui fait qu on est encore plus
exposée à tous ses processus et
mécanismes d'addiction d'ailleurs cette
sueur présence du téléphone à la même
créé une pathologie qui s'appelle
l'anneau moby qui viennent
nos mobiles faux billets c'est à dire
l'anxiété la phobie de ne pas avoir son
téléphone chansons alors tout ça c'était
la théorie le pourquoi du comment de la
diction du téléphone et d'ailleurs je me
suis beaucoup aidé d'un bouquin qui
s'appelle irrésistible airways est bon
de adam atteleurs je vous mets le lien
en descriptions se voulait le chopper et
je voulais aussi vous rappeler qu'il ya
pas de honte à être addict à son
téléphone
vous n'êtes pas nulles mauvais ou
faibles ou ce que vous voulez les
téléphones les apps etc
ça a été pensé par des gens qui sont
spécialistes de la question qu'ils sont
plus forts que nous et donc c'est pour
ça aussi qu'il faut qu'on se protège et
c'est pour ça que je vous donnais les
conseils qui vont suivre ses astuces qui
sont vraiment concrètes et là l'énorme
majorité d'entre elles je les tire de
cet homme qui s'appelle tristan harris
il était design et fils east chez google
où il a étudié les tics de la persuasion
humaines et des années plus tard il
travailla faire prendre conscience aux
gens qui sont accros à leur téléphone et
qu'il doive s'en détacher et la fonder
le center for human technology où vous
retrouverez tous les conseils que je
vais vous donner et je pense
qu'effectivement c'est la première étape
en fait se rendre compte qu'on accroc en
combien de fois j'ai été un temps par
mon téléphone lors de la rédaction de
cette même vidéo par les grandes
entreprises comme google et apple
elles ont commencé à s'intéresser au
sujet notamment apple parce que
contrairement à google son business
model n'est pas autour de notre
attention puisque apple vend des
produits et des services
là où google vend la publicité mais je
ferme la parenthèse donc ces deux
entreprises elles ont mis au sein de
leurs produits des outils qui permettent
de se rendre compte d'un traduction de
téléphone sur android c'est bien être
numérique et sur ios ces temps d'écran
sur android je sais plus s'il faut
l'activer
dès le début eyeos il faut l'activer
donc si vous l'avez pas fait vous saurez
pas votre temps d'écran sur les
dernières semaines dans tous les cas à
activer le et rendez vous compte du
temps que ça représente et demandez vous
si vous êtes ok avec ça si vous
voulait pas mettre ce temps sur autre
chose parce que vous pouvez aussi être
ok avec ça donc voilà ça dépend aussi
j'imagine de votre métier
mais l'idée c'est juste de s'en rendre
compte c'est la première étape
ensuite le deuxième élément c'est de
désactiver toutes les notifications qui
ne sont pas émises par des humains les
notifications d'appli qui relance des
trucs et c'est un machin est ce que j'ai
besoin de me faire sur sollicité par des
algorithmes je pense pas à rendre les
gens faut que je sois toujours joignable
ou pas dépend de votre niveau de
sociabilité avec les gens ensuite ça
peut sembler idiot mais passé l'écran de
son téléphone en noir et blanc
en fait souvent votre téléphone est plus
attractif que ce qu'il ya autour de vous
et c'est parfois pour des raison toute
bête hein comme la luminosité le
contraste des couleurs etc alors sur
envoyer comme sur ios vous pouvez passer
en noir et blanc très rapidement depuis
le centre de contrôle en un swipe depuis
la home page ou bien faisant un triple
tap
alors je sais trouver des liens sur
android et ios pour dire comment le
mettre en place cette nuance de gris et
les raccourcis qui vont avec pour
l'anecdote
ça fait maintenant je sais pas plus d'un
an je crois que j'utilise cette
fonctionnalité et ça m'arrive très
souvent d'aller au lit et médias c'est
fou et croyait en couleurs et en fait
c'est parce que à manger d'une passe en
couleur pour apprécier une photo ou une
vidéo
et en fait genre mon cerveau n'a pas
pensé à le remettre en noir et blanc
parce que je sais pas donc sa voix
préféré quand c'est en couleurs quoi
j'en sais rien mais en tout cas c'est
pas un truc qui sont intuitifs c'est
plutôt contre intuitif donc c'est pour
ça qu'il faut avoir conscience de tae se
force à l'oeuf et aussi le fait d'être
noir et blanc ça fait que la petite
pastille rouge de notification elle est
moins violente
elle est moins agressive et où vous avez
moins ce truc de vite vite vite résout
ce truc
paf ap l'unification dopamine etc vous
prenez un peu de distance par rapport à
ça aussi ne mettait que vos outils sur
la page principale et mettez les applis
les plus nocives le plus loin loin
visiblement téléphone chargez votre
téléphone
en dehors de votre chambre je m'en fous
que soit votre réveil acheter un réveil
est un rêve et de manière générale toute
façon augmenter votre distance avec
votre téléphone le plus possible que
vous avez travaillé sur un bureau
laissez-le loin
la semaine dernière j'ai fait un peu de
balades en forêt et c'était trop cool et
en fait me sens vraiment que mon
téléphone et dans ma poche je m'en
servais aussi pour la géolocalisation
etc
mais bref en fait typiquement dans ce
genre de cas il faut le mettre dans son
sac ça faut pas que ce soient facilement
accessibles
il y en a qui achètent même des boîtes
avec des minuteurs intégré donc puisque
calebasse et des boîtes de coûts qui a
été bénie buteur intégré donc la boîte
ne s'ouvre pas après un certain nombre
de jours d'heure etc ils le font pour
mettre un téléphone dedans 4 en bas de
la boîte ils en sont très contents
apparemment d'après les commentaires je
vous sers viendra d'exception on sait
jamais je ne juge pas à tout moment je
me lâche et vous trouvez aussi pleins
d'applications qui peuvent vous aider de
manière générale sur le site
human technology je pense qu'au final la
question qui se cache derrière cette
addiction au téléphone c'est une
question presque philosophique
en fait c'est qu'est ce que vaut mon
temps est-ce que je passais des heures
sur credit crunch ou twitter est-ce que
je passais des heures à regarder des
vidéos sur youtube
je suis pas sûr je devrais pas vous dire
ça parce que youtube va plus ou moins
recommandées cette vidéo en fonction du
temps que vous allez passer sur youtube
après l'avoir regardé c'est votre watch
times de cession voilà donc clairement
très très mauvaise stratégie de ma part
donc si jamais vous décidez de quitter
youtube à ce moment là n'est ce pas à
partager cette vidéo voilà fait pas les
bâtards met donc si notre temps ne vaut
pas ça il faut qu'on se reprenne en ont
tous et encore parce que là je vais
parler d'addiction
mais j'ai pas parlé à quel point ces
appareils peuvent être nocifs dans nos
vies notamment sur le long terme en fait
je réalise qu'il faudrait peut-être au
moins trois quatre vidéos sur sur la
nocivité du téléphone sur le long terme
sur peut-être ce que ça ce que l'impact
tout ça sur certaines générations parce
que les changements générationnels son
ouf
en termes il ya des stats qui sont assez
ouf et peut-être une vidéo aussi sur les
réseaux sociaux
et d'ailleurs cette vidéo elle arrive
puisque là c'est mon premier jour une
trentaine de jours je pense 30 jours ou
quatre semaines je sais pas encore sans
réseaux sociaux voilà donc la diction
était peut-être une première porte
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur
d'autres thématiques si toutes ces
vidéos tous
j'ai ton je vous ai parlé vous intéresse
oui si une certain nombre bref dit moi
tout ça en commentaire je les lis
absolument tous c'était un plaisir de
vous avoir aujourd'hui
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo une
nouvelle fois merci à tous les types
heures vous avez été encore plus
nombreux avec la dernière vidéo merci
parce que clairement ce genre de vidéos
j'ai parlé à sponsoriser en faisant un
jeu mobile
ça serait un peu par rapport au message
se serait pas fou
j'avoue que j'étais à deux doigts de
vous montrer toutes les applis que j'ai
sur mon téléphone notamment les
appliques aide à ça mais aussi des api
autres qui je pense sont intéressants
tout coule à avoir etc voilà si c'est
quelque chose qui vous intéresse
n'hésitez pas à me le dire je me ferai
un plaisir de vous en parler là tout de
suite je suis sur twitter point tv slash
cyrus north pour débriefer cette vidéo
parler de vous votre relation avec le
smartphone n'hésitez pas à venir
ça fait plaisir encore merci n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner si c'est pas déjà
fait love peace ciao